Trump celebrates his own personal
Festivus with the ceremonial airing of
grievances after his acquittal
Bernie gains momentum as Biden panics
and China shows the communism isn't all
that great at problem-solving I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressive VPN comm /ban
alrighty so yesterday was president
Trump's big triumphant moment now as we
said earlier this week he gave the State
of the Union address excellent State of
the Union address theatrics brilliantly
constructed well delivered and I said at
the time you know if President Trump
were like this all the time we wouldn't
fifty-five percent of the vote pretty
much everybody said that right his
advisers were saying that people around
Trump were saying that people in the
media who are who are longtime allies
the President Trump were saying that
they were saying if you could just be
contained a mr. president if you should
could just be the guy who focuses in on
what it is the American people care
about mr. president then you would be
near dominance and elections who'd be
almost impossible to stop you in
elections and then yesterday president
Trump was celebrating his acquittal
which happened the day before and he
decided that he was just going to down
eight red bulls bust through a wall like
the kool-aid man and just take a giant
dump on the Democrats
we're cheering and on the one hand of
course the one hand of course because
come on I mean President Trump is
President Trump and and this was
hilarious it was entertaining
it was Trump doing peak Trump right in
one way the State of the Union was peak
Trump because it's the best Trump can be
right it is the best version of Trump
and the best version of the best version
of Trump but this was the best version
of sort of normal Trump which is Trump
being Trump riffing doing comedy and
that has its upsides and it has its
downsides the upside is wildly
entertaining the downside is well is
this gonna win him any additional votes
the downside is do people feel like he's
the adults and I don't see the beauty
after the State of the Union is the
Nancy Pelosi looked like a child and
Trump looked like an adult now everybody
just looks like children this is the
Trump is much more entertaining child so
in any case President Trump he gave this
big presser yesterday and he went off on
his opponents and again I understand the
emotional drive to do so I understand it
I understand why he'd be angry at Adam
Schiff and Nancy Pelosi I understand why
you'd want to browbeat them I'd
understand why he'd want to go out there
and hold up the newspaper and never stop
holding up the newspaper that says Trump
acquitted this is a guy who's been put
under the gun by the Muller
investigation in Russia for two years it
turns up nothing and then immediately he
gets hit with this Ukrainian stuff and
then that is not sufficient to roust him
and
he feels like a survivor and he gets to
have himself a little party so he brings
out the pinata and he starts beating it
up so President trumpet yesterday he he
comes out swinging
he says the witch hunt started the day I
came down the elevator who's in the East
Room of the White House and man he was
letting it all hang out it was a word
salad I mean if you had to make a word
cloud for this thing it is Cloudy with a
Chance of Meatballs because weird things
just flying out of the sky references to
Bobby Richardson the former New York
Yankees second baseman full-on
descriptions of Steve Scalise getting
shot I mean everything that you could
possibly want and not want in a Trump
presser was here here was President
Trump though beginning by explaining the
witch-hunt started the day I came down
the escalator but a tremendous thing was
done over the last number of months but
really if you go back to it over the
last number of years we had the
witch-hunt it started from the day we
came down the elevator myself and our
future first lady who's with us right
now and of course he's right about this
and this led him into just bashing his
opposition so again it was really funny
who's really hilarious is it a winning
strategy for the presidents in the
United States no it doesn't have much to
do with that it doesn't have an end in
the end this is why the State of the
Union ain't gonna mean a lot and this
isn't gonna mean a lot it all washes out
and in the end what's really gonna
matter are the underlying facts which
we'll get to in a minute and which do in
fact favor of President Trump as we'll
see Trump wasn't the only one who
decided to air his grievances on
Festivus yesterday here was President
Trump holding up the Washington Post and
acknowledging full well that the
Washington Post never runs good
headlines about him which of course is
true
you can take that home money maybe we'll
frame it it's the only good headline
I've ever had in the Washington and of
course as I say this is this is Trump
you know freewheeling unbounded Trump
Unchained and that was that was the
upside so the upside was that Trump was
in a good mood the downside is that when
Trump is in a good mood he sometimes
decides to really go for it so here he
was going after the Russia stuff and
suggesting that the Russia stuff was
bleep and people are getting upset about
this again I'm not gonna bother getting
upset about this this is our politics
get over it we live in idiocracy here's
President Trump and there's nothing from
a legal standpoint this is a political
thing and every time I'd say this is
unfair let's go to court they say so you
can't go to court this is politics and
we were treated unbelievably unfairly
and you have to understand we first went
through Russia Russia Russia it was all
vote we then went through the Muller
report okay and then President Trump
finally goes after Nancy Pelosi and says
Nancy Pelosi Adam Schiff these are all
horrible horrible people horrible people
so things are getting better in
Washington DC not worse obviously I've
always said they're lousy politicians
but they do two things they're vicious
and mean vicious these people are
vicious Adam Schiff is a vicious
horrible person Nancy Pelosi is a
horrible person and she wanted to
impeach a long time ago when she said I
pray for the president I pray for the
president pray she may pray but she
prays for the opposite but I doubt she
prays at all okay so President Trump was
doing default Trump and the media lost
it over the scene this is the thing well
it is true that President Trump is asked
is acting rather unpresidential here is
that fair that he's acting on
presidential I think it's fair right I
don't feel like Lincoln Washington
Reagan like this was really in the
wheelhouse it is the reaction of the
left that justifies everything that
Trump does at least in the minds of I
think most Americans he's most Americans
go ok yeah so he's acting childish but
guess what everybody's acting childish
and he's just in the middle of a mud
fight as I've said before the perception
on the left is that President
ruined American politics the reality is
that President Trump was the coroner who
declared American politics dead the
people who actually ruin American
politics pre-existed Trump it turns out
that politics existed before Donald
Trump became a politician he only became
a politician in 2015 it turns out that
politics had been on a really really
sharp downslope for quite a while before
that we're going to get to one of the
suspects in the murder of American
politics in just from actually a couple
politics we'll get to that in just one
moment first let's talk about the
reality there are a lot of people out
there and they're looking to steal money
from you one of the ways new ways that
they're looking to steal money from you
is that they will actually steal
ownership of your home I don't mean
they're gonna like break in your house
and squat there and then just not let
you in I mean that they will steal the
title to your home let me tell you about
Debora her home was literally stolen I
don't mean that thieves actually stole
stuff online scammers stole ownership to
her home which is one of the reasons you
should consider home title lock Debra
said and I quote criminals found the
title to our home online and filed
forged documents claiming they owned it
she says I was evicted from my own home
and 85 grand and equity stolen nobody
believes you can get your home stolen
this easily but as we know hackers we've
gotten really sophisticated online
criminals have gotten really
sophisticated and there's just too much
information online home titles are kept
online and thieves will hunt for them
now forge documents to make it look like
you sold your home and then they can
borrow against your home until you're
broke no insurance or bank will protect
you from this type of crime because it's
just a to new home title lock it does so
go to home title lock calm right now
register your address to see if your
home's title has been tampered with
already if so call the cops if not
register your home for 60 risk-free days
of protection at home title lock calm
that is home title lock calm go check
them out right now home title lock calm
and protect what may be your main source
of wealth and equity your home with home
title lock comma K so as I say president
Trump gives this fairly ridiculous
presser and it was I mean let's just be
real about this it was hilarious but can
also be ridiculous many things can be
true ones that things can be
entertaining and also ridiculous
see every Michael Bay movie like ever or
John woos face offered many things are
ridiculous and also wildly entertaining
okay but the the tut-tutting is what
made trump president and maybe the
tut-tutting that keeps trump president
what i mean by that is that the wild
misperception that american politics in
the absence from is a
perfectly healthy organism and American
politics without Trump is perfectly
great and that it's just Trump who
ruined everything is such myopic
bullcrap it really is it's not true at
all if you want to talk about the
institutions and the people who ruin
American politics long before Trump ever
came on the scene you're gonna have to
look across the aisle to Nancy Pelosi so
Nancy Pelosi really let the cat out of
the bag the other night when she ripped
up from State of the Union address
because she'd been trying to do this
whole I'm above all of this I'm so I'm
above all of this
I am a I'm the adult in the room and
then at the end of the State of the
Union in pre pre-ordered fashion where I
mean she had if she had planned this she
tore up president from State of the
Union dress
we know she planned this because there's
actual video of her pre ripping the
paper because she want to make sure that
her hands could actually get through the
paper it's why she knew that she wasn't
gonna try to rip up the entire speech at
once she separated into several parts I
mean she were after you she practiced
this thing right so it was preordained
childishness his pre-planned
childishness and this has been the
nature of American politics for a long
time Trump does not pre-planned right
Trump is just I'm gonna go out there and
spew childishness
but the Democrats it's been pre-planned
it's been organized and it's been backed
by the media so the media we're going
nuts yesterday over president Trump let
me show you the media before I get to
Pelosi because there are really two
suspects in my view in the death of
American politics as I say I think from
to the corner not the murderer so what
are the actual suspects there are two
real suspects in my view suspect number
one is the media and suspect number two
are the Democrats who work and glove
with the media in the media are suspects
because the media have been acting
childish since day one it was the media
who are promoting the Bush's Hitler
Bush's awful bushes lying about the war
in Iraq Bush is the a danger to the
community he's a he's a chimp he's an
idiot they do the same thing with Ronald
Reagan they've been doing it for decades
and then it turns out that the American
people bridled against that and they
went to other sources of information and
the media just doubled down on all of
this the media lost all of their
legitimacy long before Trump came on the
scene again it's so funny the media
declared Trump the murderer of the media
cuz he says be because he says things
like fake news all the time as they
think meaning oh my god oh my god
attacks on the press hey guys we all
knew that you were fake news Trump just
said it Newt Gingrich said it in 2012 we
got a bump in the Republican primaries I
think this has been a Wong going
narrative on the right and it is not
untrue and when we say your fake news
doesn't
everything that you report is fake it
means that all of you who portray
yourselves as the journalistic
explainers of the world all of you who
portray yourselves as the objective
journalists who are attempting to just
bring fat and separate it from opinion
nearly all of you are Democrats and you
filter everything through that Democrat
lens that's what makes you fake news if
you think you or if you say you were
opinion news you're not fake then you're
exactly what you say you are but you
don't and so this is why every time
Trump does something and the media
reveal their own bias and reveal their
own predilections all they are doing is
underscoring why Trump is the coroner
not the murderer so here is here's what
CNN was doing during Trump's speech
yesterday I mean that this was their
Chiron right this is their Chiron their
Chiron is supposed to be the objective
description of what is going on no
editorial ization instead of Trump
speaks from East Room in acquittal
celebration their Chiron yesterday said
Trump vindictive and vulgar in
impeachment acquittal celebration okay
that's it that's editorializing it's
clear editorializing so I'm supposed to
think that President Trump ripping on
CNN is somehow inappropriate when CNN is
ripping on Trump now you may think that
it was vindictive and vulgar I mean it
was pretty vindictive I think it was far
less vulgar but regardless that is edits
editorializing that is not an objective
description of reality at least not in
it again you want to give your opinion
that's fine but don't pretend that that
is an objective description of reality
and then you had Gloria Borger and
Brianna Keilar going off on Trump on CNN
yesterday and really just clutching at
their pearls not just saying not just
rolling their eyes and saying okay
that's Trump being Trump and that's what
Trump does instead it was just how could
anyone do this kind of thing in American
politics American politics the home how
could we do all this come on you have
been watching the President of the
United States with an unscripted
vindictive at times profane angry
rambling response to his impeachment
acquittal to start it out with the
president coming out into the East Room
to ruffles and flourishes and then
immediately turned into an avalanche of
grievance against everybody it was
vindictive as you pointed out it was
full of revenge it was mean-spirited it
was poisonous it was spiteful Wow can
you clutch those pearls any Harry clutch
Perls Anya harder they're gonna turn
into diamonds I mean seriously it's it's
it's pretty astonishing
and again then when Trump says you guys
hate me it's like well yeah they do and
they pre-existed him
okay CNN was around and criticized long
before this I mean I was on CNN in like
2014 before Donald Trump was running for
president talking explicitly about the
fact that during the Gaza war that was
happening between Hamas in Israel that
Hamas could not have had better
spokespeople than CNN
I mean cNN has been biased for an
extraordinarily long time so again the
media wished to make it that president
Trump's childishness and vindictiveness
and thin-skinned Indus that all of that
is the death of American policy since
like know Trump is just the symptom and
also the coroner of everything that is
going on CNN's John Harwood doing the
same routine so John Harwood comes out
he says well this guy is in
psychological distress weird I don't
remember them psychoanalyzing Barack
Obama when he was literally crying
during some press conferences about mass
shootings I don't remember them doing
like a deep dive into his psychology I
just remember them celebrating his
emotion I don't remember when Barack
Obama was saying things about bringing
guns to knife fights politically them
talking about Barack Obama's vindictive
nature or in 2009 during the financial
meltdown when he suggested that he would
let the pitchforks have the bankers I
don't remember people in the media
suggesting well isn't that a bit
vindictive and spiteful no then they
were busy celebrating Barack Obama it's
it but when when Donald Trump is Donald
Trump then all of a sudden we're gonna
go into full psychological analyses by
John Harwood who last I checked is not
either a psychologist or a psychiatrist
but in any case here was Harwood this
was a very disturbing tableau for the
country it was dark because he's made
clear that his mind is dark this is
somebody in deep psychological distress
right now self pitying insecure angry he
said almost plaintively at the end when
he was reading a text from struck to
Page we said I'm a good person I'm not a
bad person he was sort of imploring
people to accept that view of him and
the more that you get from media on this
score the more Trump dumping all over
the media like okay fine okay fine I
mean at least Chris Matthews says who he
is but Chris Matthews you know lays it
out what the media actually thinks it
this is where I like Chris Matthews
Chris Matthews didn't hide in the ball
right I mean Chris Matthews is of the
left he knows he's a
he says he's on the left it's the people
like Andrea Mitchell proclaim they're
not on the left or the problem but Chris
Matthews yesterday's that doesn't say
today's a cult leader he's a cult leader
like Jim Jones gonna feed everything
kool-aid everything's gonna die you know
Jim Jones was supported by half the
Democrats in Congress
he's a cult leader he's coming for a
fight to the death which by the way
would be like amazing Holly in any case
Chris Matthews go go go come out with a
shoe get many rumpled and they talking
about banishing banishing Mitt Romney
from the party that's the language of a
cult banishment it's not a language of
the Constitution or of our American
tradition the banishment for the one guy
who dared the United States Senate to
vote to convict I think it's also an
attempt by the president basically tell
his troops here's the fighting line
right now we're going after everybody
who went after us we're gonna fight to
the death
we're gonna get him so suspect number
one in the death of the American
political scene the media
okay the media have a lot of blame to
carry on I know they're a bunch of
people on the left and they say well
yeah polarization of the media is the
problem the polarization of the media is
not the problem
dishonesty in the media is the problem
and there are people out there on the
left hook well you have a leftist cheers
tumblr on your on your table aren't you
contributing to the death of American
policies no I'm honest about who we are
over here right we don't really like the
political left very much by which I mean
not liberals but people who wish to shut
down debate people who believe that
people should be a platform for having a
finally eight an absolutely mainstream
point I'd rather that everybody be
honest like Chris Matthews is then
dishonest like the folks over at CNN
okay so suspect number one members of
the media gets a suspect number two in
just one second first let us talk about
something that will make you comfortable
I'm talking about Tommy John underwear
dudes Valentine's Day is just around the
corner sometimes you're loving
significant other means at treating at
yourself well too good news Tommy John
is the most stylish comfortable
functional underwear out there they have
limited edition of Valentine's Day gift
sets whether for you or for your
partner's show you care by replacing
your old-fashioned tattered underwear
with something you can be proud of I'm
talking about Tommy John Tommy John
makes men's and women's products that
really are fantastic I mean like truly
truly comfortable when you're in Tommy
John underwear the legs never ride up
the waistband never rolls down it's
impossible to get a wedgie which would
have helped me so much in high school I
can't even tell you for the lady in your
life Tommy John has officially ended
visible panty lines plus they have the
most comfortable bras on the planet to
complete her look so if you're still
looking for the perfect gift Tommy John
has limited edition
underwear and loungewear gift sets for
him and her plus all sets are up to 15%
off Tommy John is so sure that you and
your partner are gonna love their fit
and feel it's all backed by their best
pair you'll ever wear or it's free
guarantee which means if you don't love
that first pair you will get a full
refund Tommy John no adjustment needed
chap limited edition Valentine's Day
gift sets and get 20% off your first
order when you go to Tommy John comm /
Ben my wife has Tommy John products I
have Tommy John products we both love
Tommy John products I promise you your
significant other will love Tommy John
products too for Valentine's Day that's
Tommy John comm / Ben for 20% off the
most basic basically comfortable live
underwear on the market chopped
limited-edition Valentine's Day gift
sets Tommy John comm / Ben for 20% off
again that's Tommy John comm / Ben okay
so who is the other suspect in the
murder of American politics again
everybody has in the media proclaims
that it's Trump but that's a red herring
and the Democrats proclaim that it's
from but that's a red herring to Nancy
Pelosi has been around on the scene for
quite a while and Nancy Pelosi has been
a deeply polarizing figure for also
quite a while I'm old enough to remember
when just last year she refused to pass
a resolution condemning open
anti-semites at galehead Omar and
Rashida to leap inside her own caucus
I'm old enough to remember when Nancy
Pelosi declared that boycott divestment
sanctions of Israel were anti-semitic
and then half of her caucus supported
them and then she was like oh okay I
guess it's not anti-semitic anymore
Nancy Pelosi is one of the murderers
okay Nancy Pelosi at least is one of the
suspects she pretends to be the
detective right I'm going to track down
Donald Trump and I'm gonna pin him to
the wall as the adult in the room in
reality
the lady's got some the blood of
American politics that that blood
spatter from the corpse of American
politics it's all over her shoes okay
just as it is the shoes of the media
this is Murder on the Orient Express
okay there are many suspects here so
Nancy proof Nancy Pelosi yesterday she
does her own press conference and she is
also childish and wild so yes Donald
Trump's presser not gonna say it wasn't
childish wild it was childish wild and
hilarious Nancy Pelosi gave her own
presser it was childish and wild was
there any blowback whatsoever of course
not Nancy Pelosi yesterday suggested in
her press conference that Donald Trump
looked sedated now imagine if Donald
Trump had said that Nancy Pelosi looked
sedated or like she was sucking on
lemons which he did imagine if he had
said that then I mean oh look again he's
coming to kill American politics there
he is
the axe murderer of American politics
Nancy Pelosi suggests the president is
drugged and nobody says a word I mean
it's unbelievable I extended the hand of
friendship to him she welcomed him as
the president of United States to the
people's house was also an act of
kindness because I looked to me like he
was a little sedated he looked that way
last year too but he didn't want to
shake hands that was that that meant
nothing to me
it had nothing to do with my tearing of
that that came much later again this is
it's it's so childish and so petty and
so stupid but she's been around a long
time right she was the House Majority
Leader in 2006 so she's been around a
lot longer than Donald Trump pretending
that the world started spinning in 2016
is the way for Democrats to avoid their
culpability for the fact that Trump got
elected in the first place
pretending that Trump came along and he
shattered all of the norms of American
politics and broke everything that's the
way to avoid the inevitable conclusion
which is that the Democrats in the media
broke American politics and then Trump
came and he said look American politics
is dead everybody went oh that's true
and then they voted for him okay so all
of this is going to as much as I don't
like the the violation of norms my
president Trump as much as I criticize
President Trump for being ridiculous and
petty and vindictive and thin-skinned as
much as I think that he pursues dumb
strategies and going after Mitt Romney
after Mitt Romney makes his vote and
Trump gets acquitted as much as I think
all of that is foolish and
counterproductive I also recognize that
foolishness and counterproductive action
did not begin nor will they end with
President Trump which means that in the
end I think the American people are
going instead to turn to underlying
facts when it comes to the 2020 election
underlying facts like the fact that
January was a big month for jobs
according to CNBC and unseasonable a
mild January helps powered the US jobs
market to more gains with non-farm
payrolls rising 225,000 for the month
well above Wall Street estimates the
unemployment rate ticked higher to 3.6
percent but that's only because the
labor force participation rate increased
0.2 percentage points up to sixty three
point four percent which actually
matched its highest level since June
so people who have been out of the
workforce for years are re-entering the
workforce looking for jobs economists
surveyed by Dow Jones were thinking that
the payroll growth would be 158 thousand
instead payroll growth was 225 thousand
a more encompassing labor market
indicator that in
discouraged workers and those holding
part-time positions for economic reasons
also moved higher rising 0.2 percentage
points to six point nine percent again
that's because more people are we
entering the workforce the
employment-to-population ratio in the
household survey rose to sixty one point
two percent that's the highest since
November 2008 and 0.5 percentage points
higher than a year ago so basically we
are now only now starting to reach pre
recession levels of employment in the
United States relative to the general
American population because Barack Obama
did preside over the slowest job growth
in American history in terms of recovery
from a recession so that is very good
news for president Trump other very good
news for President Trump as the wages
are again accelerating so again this is
very good news for president from he's
been pointing out the difference between
himself and Barack Obama that as wages
accelerate that was not happening really
under President Obama payroll gains were
broad-based they topped the median
estimate for 165 thousand the unexpected
job strength also reflects robust gains
in weather sensitive sectors including
construction with which climb by 44,000
for the strongest growth in a year in a
none seasonably warm month weekly hours
work hell worked held at 34 point 3
hours for the third month matching the
lowest level for most of the past a
decade economists look to hours worked
for early signs of labor market
softening as companies often cut hours
before laying off workers however by the
way that should give the lie to the idea
that people are working nine jobs to
keep ends meeting they're working 60
hours a week cuz they're working two
jobs the average is thirty four point
three which is not even like a full-time
job right a full-time job would be eight
hours a day five days a week that'd be
forty hours a week so very good news for
president Trump another the labor force
grew by 574 thousand this is all very
good news for president Trump going into
the election cycle and all of this is
leading Democrats to the point of panic
and it shouldn't just be that that leads
Democrats to the point of panic it
should be the fact that Bernie Sanders
is likely to be their nominee at this
point we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about a
phenomenal Valentine's Day gift perhaps
the best Valentine's Day gift that you
can buy I'm talking about jewelry of
course but where can you get fabulous
fantastic jewelry from my friends over
at the pearl store so first of all I
know the people at the pearl source they
are fantastic I mean I know them they're
family-run business
they are really really honest and their
jewelry is just beautiful my wife has a
necklace from the pearl source she has
earrings from the pearl source beautiful
beautiful stuff at the pearl source you
get the highest quality pearl jewelry
and up to 70% off retail prices why well
because pearl source cuts out the
middleman by eliminating markups
traditionally five times the original
price and selling directly to you at the
pearl source you will find the largest
selection of pearls available anywhere
each jewelry piece is custom-made just
for you you customize your jewelry based
on pearl size quality gold type length
many other choices if you need it
quickly for Valentine's Day no problem
the pearl source offers free two-day
shipping on every single order
everything comes beautifully packaged in
an elegant jewelry box ready to be
presented as soon as it arrived in
here's the best part if you're not sure
that your taste is her taste well no
worries the pearl source comes with a
no-hassle 60 day money back guarantee so
it's risk free for a limited time
listeners to my show can take 14 percent
off your entire order for Valentine's
Day which when you're talking about 14%
is a lot go to the Pearl source calm
/ban and enter promo code been at
checkout for 14 percent off your entire
order again I know the people at the
Pearl source super honest also beautiful
beautiful jewelry go to the pearl source
comm slash been enter promo code been at
checkout for 14 percent off go straight
to the source the pearl source that is
the pearl source comm backslash pen
enter promo code been in check out for
14 percent off for Valentine's Day I
promise you she absolutely will love it
it's the finest pearl jewelry at the
best prices on line goes straight to the
source the pearls source calm /ban used
that promo clip n for 14% off okay we're
gonna get back to the 2020 race which
again is a mess for Democrats
increasingly a mess for Democrats first
quick message about the show as you know
we rely in part on our advertisers to
help keep this mic hot and the lights on
one thing that's really important for us
is that we know who's listening until we
make sure that we're featuring
advertisers that you folks actually want
to do business with so if you have just
a few minutes to spare I'd really
appreciate it if you visited the pod
survey comm and fill out a short survey
about yourself again that's the pod
survey comm throw out that short survey
about yourself once we have enough data
that helps us find advertisers who
actually want to hear from you so visit
the pod survey com
it'll take just a few minutes like five
minutes and complete the survey help my
team bring you advertisers who you want
to hear from and help us out it helps
our advertisers out the pod survey that
comments I was asking you to do it
please really appreciate it okay so the
Democratic 2020 primaries
are a mess for the Democrats according
to 538 Bernie Sanders is now a
one-in-two odds on favorites to be the
nominee for president of the United
States for the Democratic Party and when
a majority of the delegates they're
forecasting that he will win above a
majority of Delegates about 1,700
delegates they are forecasting that Joe
Biden will come in second and Pete Budi
judge will come in third they're really
forecasting that because they're
thinking that Biden is going to win a
bunch of Delegates in the south
particularly among black voters see
here's the problem
pee Buddha judge is indeed surging
there's no question that people who to
judge is surging the latest polls in New
Hampshire show Gouda judge actually
challenging Bernie Sanders for primacy
the best news here by the way would be
for Pete buddy judge to win New
Hampshire outright for Biden all right
that would be the best news for Biden
because if he blew to judge wins New
Hampshire outright I know the
conventional wisdom is that then he will
go on he'll become the moderate lane
Democrat I don't think that's correct I
think that if people were to judge wins
New Hampshire the person that hurts most
is Bernie because bernie is widely
expected to win New Hampshire if bootie
judge wins Iowa and he wins New
Hampshire then you will get the
candidates of sort of the white upper
upper class versus the candidate who's
more popular with minorities so people
are assuming that Buddha judge is
cutting into Biden and there's truth to
that in places like Iowa in New
Hampshire but if Buddha judge starts to
actually overcome Bernie in state after
state then what you're going to see is
people move away from some of these
other candidates to counter Buddha judge
and that's why you're gonna see by can
go after Buddha judge tonight in New
Hampshire the latest poll statistics
show that Sanders is only very narrowly
leading Buddha judge the newest Boston
Globe Suffolk Poll has them in a dead
heat it has blue to judge of 23 in
Sanders at 24 the Emerson poll that came
out the same day it has Sanders further
ahead at 32 with blue to judge of 23 and
Monmouth which came out the day before
had Sanders within spitting distance of
Buddha judge Sanders at 24 and Buddha
judge at 20 bottom line is that that
lead has shrunk dramatically for Bernie
Sanders who judges getting a big bump
from Iowa
part of that is due to the media
coverage Bernie did win the most votes
in Iowa but he's unlikely to win the
most delegates it's basically a dead
heat and Bernie was expected to do
really well in Iowa while budda judge
was kind of left for dead a few weeks
ago
well Buddha judge obviously did really
well in Iowa and now he's doing really
well in New Hampshire now these are very
very white states and either Bernie nor
Budi judge
a lot of black support which is why I
suggest that if Buddha judge actually
overcomes Burnie then that's gonna
leavin up in a pathway for Joe Biden in
places like South Carolina because
Buddha judge does not have the national
organization that Bernie has Bernie has
been starting to make some inroads into
minority communities in ways that Buddha
judge simply has not all the Buddha
judge is a far more innately talented
politician than Bernie Sanders's
Buddha judge has also been able to work
this magic where he pretends that he's
moderate when he is absolutely not
moderate I mean super not moderate by
the way Biden is completely collapsing
in New Hampshire as well Biden is
falling apart Elizabeth Warren is
stagnant I think she is toast Biden at
least can make the case to his people
that if he holds on to South Carolina
maybe he'll do okay there but again the
polls in South Carolina have been
tightening fairly a lot as well Biden is
now running at like 11 percent in the
last two polls in New Hampshire just as
sastra stuff for Joe Biden he's gonna
have to show some signs of life to his
supporters or he is going to be toast
forthwith now with all of that said the
latest East Carolina you pull still
shows Biden blowing everybody out in
South Carolina right it shows Biden at
37 this is taking pre Iowa though Biden
at 37 Tom Styer at 19 and 19 and that
actually is a sign of possibility for
Michael Bloomberg right because Michael
Bloomberg is just like Tom Steyer except
more so Tom Steyer has spent like 75
million bucks Bloomberg has spent 200
million dollars on this race
particularly in Super Tuesday States so
this race is a complete mess the person
with the easiest path by far at this
point is Bernie because bernie is the
most well known he's got a machine he's
got a movement behind him and he has a
lot of small dollar donors that are just
throwing off money right all of that it
shows benefit for him but the
fragmentary nature of the field and the
possibility that you could see let's say
that let's say that that Bernie well
let's say that Biden falls apart so
badly in South Carolina he gets out well
that opens the door to either Budaj edge
or Bloomberg or somebody else so it's a
mess out there Biden for his part is
panicking he's prepping for the debate
but what exactly is he going to do that
he hasn't done before presumably he's
gonna have to get aggressive with Bernie
presumably he's gonna have to get
aggressive mostly with Budaj an attack
blue judge who a judge has pretty been
fairly smooth on defense a Buddha judge
has been able to sort of push off all of
the attacks on him and also I'm not sure
that the experience
Tech really matters much to Democrats
since they elected to the presidency
twice a guy who had had five minutes in
the United States Senate if they really
wanted somebody who had done anything in
his life they wouldn't be looking at
Bernie who's been a useless piece of
crap for the last six decades and the
bottom line is that they're looking for
somebody who's sort of mirrors vision
makes them feel good about themselves
and Buddha judge is doing that far more
so than Biden this is the problem for
Joe Biden according to the Washington
Post outside the castle themed Radisson
Hotel where Joe Biden has been staying
his campaign bus was parked and ready
for events but on Thursday just five
days before the crucial primary here the
candidate was nowhere to be found
Biden spent Thursday gathered with his
top advisors at his home in Wilmington
Delaware seeking a reset and perhaps a
last-ditch effort to save his candidacy
beginning with a debate on Friday night
held no public events he's set to appear
on all the sunday shows on Sundays he
needs the publicity following dismal
results in the Iowa caucuses that have
rattled many in his orbit his campaign
is now simultaneously trying to lower
expectations here some suggesting that
consider a finish as low as third place
of victory while bracing for a second
straight difficult Election Day in one
troublesome sign for the financially
strapped campaign it canceled nearly one
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in TV
ads in South Carolina which votes
February 29th and move the spending to
Nevada this February 22nd contest
follows New Hampshire's the move seemed
to acknowledge the Biden's campaign
cannot sustain a continued run of bad
news which of course is true he needs to
win Nevada outright dick Harpootlian
South Carolina state senator said from a
Biden perspective there's going to be a
course correction in all three states
before Super Tuesday he's got to have
sharper elbows he suggested those inside
the campaign realized the gravity of the
moment that Biden had to better explain
the differences with his opponents the
problem is that his campaign is not
exactly built for comeback kid Bill
Clinton New Hampshire type moments right
it's an old campaign it's a doddering
campaign he hasn't bothered to do any
the groundwork he just assumed he's
gonna sail to the nomination that he was
owed the nomination and people didn't
feel that way about him in the same way
that they felt about Hillary Clinton
our Putin says history may right the
best thing that ever happened to Joe
Biden was getting gut punched in Iowa it
woke him up at will cos campaign up his
supporters up they were complacent
you've got to talk about the other guy
but at least on Thursday was the other
guy talking about Biden bootie dredge
was going after Biden he said if your
focus is on electability it ain't Biden
who's the most electable it's me now in
a second we're gonna get to Bernie vs.
boo to judge because now this is a three
candidate race and really one of those
candidates is in serious trouble
right that candidate who's in serious
trouble the most obviously is is Biden
and we'll talk about the radicalism of
people who to judgment she's been
completely ignored right he's been able
to pretend that he's actually a member
of the moderate coterie simply because
bernie is an outward out-and-out
socialist and buddha judge isn't a
Buddha judge is no moderate we'll get to
that in just one second first the Second
Amendment is incredibly important the
reason that I am a gun owner is for
ideological and self-defense reasons the
Second Amendment was designed to protect
your rights the whole purpose of the
Second Amendment is to protect you from
a government that would violate the
Second Amendment you know I feel really
strongly about this our founding fathers
also felt strongly about this and you
know who else feel strongly about this
the people over at Bravo Company
manufacturing Bravo Company started in
the garage from Marine veteran in in
Hartland Wisconsin the people at Bravo
Company MFG support the right of
responsible private individuals have the
access and ability to employ the same
tools as civilian law enforcement as a
means of defending ourselves our loved
ones our communities our freedoms should
a threatening situation ever arise and
the purpose of again owning these guns
is that a threatening situation never
will arise there an inherent deterrent
Bravo Company is not a sporting arms a
supporting arms company they design
engineer manufacture life-saving
equipment BCM assumes that when a rifle
leaves their shop it will be used in a
life-or-death situation by a responsible
citizen law enforcement officer or
soldier overseas so quality is of utmost
value to them every single components of
a BCM rifle is hand assembled and tested
by Americans in heartland Wisconsin to a
life-saving standard you can check them
out by the way over at Bravo Company
imfg their products are just
astoundingly good they've got everything
from m4 carbines to marksman rifles to
to stocks to to grips I mean they've got
everything that you're possibly going to
need it's all top-quality and I've
really checked it out to learn more
about Bravo company manufacturing head
on over to Bravo Company MFG comm where
you can discover more about their
products special offers and upcoming
news that is Bravo Company MFG calm
again Bravo Company MFG dot-com go check
them out really great folks okay also
one more note in July last year I told
you about this awesome podcast Apollo 11
what we saw hosted by my friend Bill
little well the show took you back in
time to experience living the Space Age
now bill has a new season of the show
this time bill takes you back to the
Cold War the series is fantastic the
story is well told the setting is
brilliantly descriptive you get a sense
of what it was like to live through
major events like the Berlin Airlift the
Korean War the Cuban Missile Crisis the
space race he's my
Suns are tied together to give you a
sense of the big picture the apocalypse
that never happened has the host bill
does pull you in he makes the story
engaging and entertaining and
fascinating and riveting we're having
him on the radio show a little bit later
today whether you remember living
through the events or whether you do not
we've already released two episodes of
the twelve part series so you already
have something to catch up on
you should go listen now because it has
never been more relevant than this year
where the left is going full-blown
communist in many of their policies and
their language the podcast emphasizes
the battle not only for civilization but
not only for capitalism but also for
civilization all you have to do just go
over to Daley wire.com slash Cold War
and start listening to this incredibly
important story that is really super
bleeped old if you wonder why communism
was evil why Reagan labeled it the evil
empire go check out Daley wire.com at
slash Cold War it's really solid stuff
also it is that glorious time of the
week when I give a shout out to a daily
water subscriber today it's Matt on
Twitter he understands how to enjoy
life's simple pleasures in this picture
matt's elite beverage vessel is sitting
outside in front of his transportation
from the future the caption reads real
daily wire riding my one wheel listening
to mention pero sipping my hot leftist
tears on a cold winter day what could be
more wonderful wonderful hashtag leftist
here's tumblr the answer matt nothing
zero things we are so glad we could
bring a little joy to your humdrum life
now don't go living out your mad splat
twitter handle literally stay safe on
your future moby oh my friend thank you
for the picture now gang final note if
you haven't noticed already this is
crazier you need updates you need
everything you need our app you're gonna
need to subscribe over a daily wire so
you can get all the things we're giving
you 20% off on the memberships and what
exactly are you waiting for again all
you have to use is promo code GW 2020
what do members get well again our
articles had free access to all of our
live broadcasts and our show library the
full three hours of the ben shapiro show
select bonus content access to the
mailbag and now my election insight
op-eds plus our new all-access tier gets
you into live online Q&A discussions
with me Andrew Klavan Matt Walsh Michael
moles plus our sites writers and special
guests let us answer your questions and
help you say one step ahead of the left
if you haven't already download the
daily wire app so you can get push
notifications for breaking news in
special coverage all of this is awesome
again use promo code DW 2020 for 20% off
by the way you're seeing clips here of
the Ben Shapiro Sunday special that is
coming back in short order
join today stay informed on all things
2020 again that's
DW 2020 where the largest
fastest-growing conserved a podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so here's the problem for Democrats they
are not moderates like nobody who's
running as a moderate with maybe the
exception of Biden even he is not
particularly moderate even the ones who
are sort of moderate like Michael
Bloomberg are trying to pretend they're
not moderate because if they acknowledge
that they are moderate then they have a
problem which is the debates doesn't
like them very much
so instead what you get is one candidate
basically the difference between Buddha
judge and Sanders the Buddha judge
presence he's a moderate and Sanders is
not right so Sanders just says the the
quiet part out loud I'm sort of sort of
even he lies a little bit right he says
he's a socialist but only like only like
Finland and Denmark only like Finland
and Denmark right this is his routine
all the time here is Bernie yesterday he
was asked how would you convince
Americans concerned about the socialist
label to vote for you and here's Bernie
lying about what he actually thinks my
definition of socialism needless to say
is a little bit different and I think if
you look at countries around the world
look at countries in Scandinavia Finland
Sweden Denmark what do they have
everybody in those countries has health
care is a human right they bury a little
bit the Pine Lodge it is a right you
don't have to take out your wallet it is
available to all people okay again
nationalized health care does not mean
that you live in a socialist country
means he wants to socialized medicine
which by the way is wildly unpopular in
the United States because his version of
socializing medicine is not the version
that you see in Switzerland or that you
see in Singapore where there's an
individual mandate and then you buy into
a private but not heavily regulated
health insurance sector instead Bernie's
vision is that you are just taxed and
then the government borrows a lot of
money and then the government provides
you directly health care and doctors and
nurses and hospitals work directly for
the government which is the worst form
of socialized medicine but when Bernie
says his brand of socialism is Finland
in Denmark I'm just wondering when it
shifted from Cuba in the USSR and
Venezuela which he's praised fulsomely
all of them like what is his why why if
you actually ask the politicians of
Denmark whether they are a socialist
country they will tell you straight up
no in fact the prime minister of Denmark
recently spoke at Harvard Kennedy School
of Government and somebody asked him
about the socialism in Denmark he said
what socialism or a capitalist country
so Bernie's just lying here but it's Oh
Bernie why even Bernie lies about how
radical he is but at least Bernie is a
little more honest than the other people
in his in his caucus Bernie says yeah
sure my economic blog just I want to
climate change and yes there will be
some job loss I will
there will be some job loss well yeah
people are not gonna be I mean he's
cutting ads against himself at this
point Trump does not believe in climate
change and they're not believing in the
reality of climate change what he is
doing is threatening the very well-being
of kids and future generations and that
is unacceptable but from an economic
point of view is also one we can create
yes there will be some job loss I
acknowledge that but what we can do is
create a heck of a lot more jobs as we
retrofit out all the buildings as we
move to wind solar geothermal and other
sustainable energies when he's talking
about his nuts
I mean it's fully nuts the amount of
wind power that his presence in the
United States powering the electrical
grid is is de minimis effectively okay
so so when he's talking about there will
be job loss welcome to the ads against
Bernie Sanders and here's the inherent
problem for the Democrats Bernie may be
the most viable candidate in the
primaries because again he has the
lowest he has the highest base right
here that the floor for him is the
highest it's kind of like Trump in 2016
the floor for him is very high it's 2025
% that may be enough to get him through
the primaries because that 2025 starts
to look like 30 or 35 as the field
consolidates but if Bernie's actually in
a general election you know though the
worries about his electability aren't
gonna go away they're not I mean burning
himself acknowledged the voter turnout
in Iowa where he's declared massive
victory the voter turnout in Iowa was
abysmal like 170,000 people showed up to
vote in Iowa that's the same number that
showed up to vote in 20 in 2016 and it
is about 40 50 thousand lower than
showed up to vote in 2008 they were
hoping it would be 240,000 it was way
lower than that Bernie acknowledges that
he keeps he was asked about his
electability to I mean he has it
literally last night whose axis about
his electability and his answer was well
a lot of young people showed up to vote
so we're gonna turn out audiences that
are never historically voted that was
exactly what Jeremy Corbyn said in
Britain and then nobody showed up to
vote here's Bernie acknowledging that
nobody showed up in Iowa either senator
a key part of your argument for the
general election and your electability
is that you're gonna boost turnout by
bringing all these people into the
process that haven't been voting Iowa
turnout doesn't look like it was higher
than last time does that concern you it
does and I would have liked to have seen
a higher turnout and I think
I can probably speak for every other
candidate yeah except that if you win
then your case has to be yeah the
turnout was great because people are
enthused except what if people aren't
that enthused herein lies the problem
Bernie can't even acknowledge that how
he's gonna get his health care plans
enacted because he's not gonna get them
enacted nobody's gonna vote for this
crap earlier this week Vice President
Biden said and I quote the Speaker of
the House isn't for it most Democrats in
Congress are not for it so how's it
going to pass talking about your plan
how's it gonna move how does it get done
well actually most members of Congress I
believe are I think the majority are on
board for a medicare-for-all in the
house not the Senate this is how you do
it and and this is the answer I'm going
to give tonight time and time again so
what our campaign is about and I
admitted it is a different type of
campaign because I'm not here to tell
you vote for me and I'm gonna do all
these great things ain't gonna happen
that way it never happens that way
instead I'm here to tell you that I'm
gonna say that we should do it and then
magically you look home alright and I
will be riding on its back he doing a
couple pudding and medical will just
happen Hillary Clinton was criticizing
Bernie correctly she says listen he
keeps promising the moon he can't
deliver she was on Ellen doing her
non-presidential tour and she gets this
right now here's the problem for the
Democrats democratic party members the
base they don't really care they just
want to hear the promises they don't
want to hear how they actually get
implemented but here was Hillary making
the points that Bernie can't effectuate
any of this stuff you've got to be
responsible for what you say and what
you say you're going to do we need to
rebuild trust in our fellow Americans
and in our institutions and if you
promise the moon and you can't deliver
the moon then that's gonna be one more
indicator of how you know we just can't
trust each other so it's not it's not
good theater it's not maybe good
politics anymore but I think you should
tell people what you mean mean what you
say and have some sense of
responsibility for how you would get
anything done that you talked about I
can't believe in medicines but Hillary
Clinton's being more honest than Bernie
Sanders that is a reality what she's
saying right there meanwhile speaking of
dishonest people peabody judge has been
masquerading as the as the moderate
alternative to Bernie Sanders and he's
been able to get away with it because
bernie is so off the wall loony left and
because Joe
has been collapsing and he's been almost
physically collapsing but Budaj edges no
moderate either there is no moderation
inside this Democratic Party people who
judge was on the view yesterday and he
was asked by Meghan McCain about late
term abortion like partial birth
abortion and people who judge refused to
even to even disassociate from late term
abortion which is madness okay
very few Democrats are into the idea of
being able to abort a baby at 8 months
in the womb okay like I don't know who's
for this but your that is an evil
position that once you hit 35 weeks of
pregnancy you should be looking at the
possibility of killing the child are you
out of your damn mind but people who
judge thinks that should be perfectly
legal here's Meghan McCain incredulously
asking him the question anybody
seriously think that's what these cases
are about this is a late-term situation
then by definition it's one where a
woman was expecting to carry the
pregnancy to term then she gets the most
perhaps devastating news of her life
talking about families that that may
have picked out a name maybe assembling
a crib and they learn something
excruciating and are faced with this
terrible choice and I don't know what to
tell them
morally about what they should do I just
know that I trust her in her decision
medically or morally and isn't gonna be
any better because the government is
commanding her to do it is absolute
madness I mean what are you talking
about as eugenics they're right when
somebody gets horrible news that baby is
going to have some sort of terrible
disease right before birth they just had
to kill the baby what about that doesn't
why should the limiting point be birth
at that point also it is simply untrue
when he says that all late term
abortions by their very nature our
people who get bad news that's just not
true late term abortions as it very
often turns out are done for the same
reason that the vast majority of
abortions are done out of choice and
convenience so the the fact that the
peabody judge is overtly defending late
term abortion on a moral level is pretty
astonishing stuff people who judges know
moderate he's not even close to a
moderate and even things that he says
that sound modern are not actually
moderate so let me give you an example
yesterday people who judge did the CNN
Town Hall and he was talking about T
about how teachers are paid and his
suggestion is that America do better if
we pay teachers at leg doctors now this
is ridiculous on a couple of scores one
teachers do not go to school for as long
doctors nor do they have his particular
skillset nor is there a supply and
demand problem with teachers okay the
fact is that if you're a first grade
teacher you are incredibly valuable to
first graders you're not as valuable to
first graders as a doctor is to somebody
who just had a heart attack
nor have you had the training there's a
serious supply and demand issue here it
is fairly easy to get trained to be a
first-grade teacher it is very very
difficult to be trained as a doctor I
know this because once again my wife is
a doctor which only gives me credibility
insofar as I accompanied her on that
decade-long journey of crap in order
that she become a doctor to suggest that
she should be paid the same as a third
grade teacher see in order for this to
make sense what he's saying is teachers
should be paid like doctors what he
really means his doctor should be paid
like teachers because he's not
suggesting that teachers get paid
$300,000 a year if he were suggesting
that teachers be paid $300,000 a year
he'd be very much in favor of private
education because an open competition
he'd be anti teachers unions which are
the reason the teachers don't get paid
more
the reason the teachers do not get paid
more on an individual level not an
average level on an individual level is
because no matter how good a teacher you
are you may be booted out of your job
because of seniority rules established
by unions in order to protect older
teachers who may not be as good and have
been in the job longer but here's people
who to judge saying silly things I mean
this is this is bura again Bernie
pie-in-the-sky kind of stuff America
would be better if we pay teachers like
doctors yeah America would be better if
we paid line cooks like doctors but the
problem is it's much easier to to
nationalize systems and have doctors
paid like teachers then to then to do
the hard thing that people would judge
would never want to do and that is
actually pay teachers like doctors based
on skill set based on the performance of
their students and based on the need for
the skill level of particular teacher
he's not willing to do that
I'd love to hear him explain to Randi
Weingarten over at the American
Federation of Teachers why he is now in
favor of a of a merit-based pay system
for teachers because he clearly is not
you should have a little more support in
fact a lot more support I would argue
that if we could honor our teachers a
little more like we do our soldiers and
pay our teachers a little more like we
do our doctors this entire country would
be a better place and again being
married to a teacher I have seen just
how much teachers put in and invest in
not just having to pick up supplies for
your classroom but emotionally invest in
the well-being of kids conversations
with parents long after hours late
nights
papers and yet look at what you're up
against yeah well you're up against is a
system that is stacked against you in
terms of a government that pays you not
all that much based on your merit but
instead pays you based on union
contracts that you have signed with the
state well what you're also stacked up
against the governmental system that
demands things from you
that really ought to be put on the back
of parents I mean the fact is that if
you want to look at school performance
the first thing that you ought to look
at is not the teachers the first thing
that you ought to look at is the family
structures of the students because that
is what is correlative I mean that's
true that is not a racial point that is
a that is a simple demographic point
across races that parents who have more
time and more energy and more focus on
their kids with regard to their
schooling are going to do better no
matter what school they go to but again
this is all pie in the sky non-set
buddha judges just as radical as Bernie
he just hides it better that's all I
mean listen this is ridiculous Buddha
judge says he's gonna pay for his health
care plan which of course is Medicaid
for all who want it and he acknowledges
that this is basically the first step
toward Medicare for all because once you
establish a public option paid for by
taxpayers and employers are now going to
have an incentive to not give their
employees health care at which point
they can toss people onto the privy
public rolls you're gonna have to
increase the expenditure on taxpayer
dollars the public plan will be funded
by Congress what is popular for Congress
to do is to continue to fund that at
exorbitant rates undercutting insurance
companies and eventually you run the
insurance companies out of business and
you end up with Medicare for all right
that is what the public option is
designed to do
here's people to judge saying the way
he's gonna pay for that is by repealing
Trump's tax cuts ain't enough money
there my friend if you think that simply
by repealing these from tax cuts which
by the way disproportionately benefited
people in the middle class then good
luck to you all we've got to do to pay
for it is take two steps part of that
1.5 comes from rolling back a trump
corporate tax cut that went to the
wealthiest and the biggest corporations
didn't do us any good has created a huge
deficit we're all that that was most
no it doesn't do most of the work and
when you do corporate cat tax increases
corporations lay people off what do you
think they are doing with their money
they're not just paying it out to people
and if they do pay it out to people you
know what those people do then then pay
income tax the economic either
illiteracy or or dishonesty here is
astonishing but again as Biden collapses
Budi judge is picking up the pieces
which opens the way for Michael
Bloomberg who is writing full-on op-eds
in The New York Times about fixing
income inequality as the ninth richest
person on earth so good luck to him in
all of this the Democratic Party may be
irrevocably broken at this point which
is why it is vital that President Trump
not blow it on the shoals of his own
emotionality because seriously seriously
do you want these people running the
country is that what you would like okay
time for a quick thing I like and then a
quick thing that I hate things that I
like I talked about things that are both
stupid and entertaining silly and
entertaining and I mentioned Michael Bay
movies well one of the great Michael Bay
movies of all time is of course of the
rock first Sean Connery Nicolas Cage
Nicolas Cage being full Nicolas Cage
Sean Connery being the best thing ever
cuz Sean Connery is tremendous ed Harris
who I love in this movie also great
action movie the rock here's a little
bit of the preview there's a hostage
situation on Alcatraz hostage 81
tourists the rock become a tourist
attraction
it's just spectacular ly wonderful and
dumb and entertaining and it's great and
Sean Connery makes everything better
Sean Connery is just the best so if you
if you've never seen the rock you're
missing out it's great it is the Nicolas
Cage made a series of really cheesy and
wonderful action flecks in the in the
90s ranging from face-off which I've
recommended on the show to Conair which
I'm sure at some point I will recommend
on the show and and the rock may be the
best of them it really is a great movie
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
so it turns out that you know it's a not
great place to live a communist country
which is weird because every time you
hear from people like Bernie Sanders
he's talking about the wonderful things
that are accomplishable if you have a
one-party system run by people who truly
care about equality but here's the
reality
China is a horrible place to live the
latest evidence that China is a horrible
place to live courtesy of the New York
Times the Chinese authorities resorted
to increasingly extreme measures in
Wuhan on Thursday to try to help the
spread of the deadly coronavirus
ordering house-to-house searches
rounding up the sick and warehousing
them in enormous quarantine centers the
urgent seemingly improvised steps come
amid a worsening humanitarian crisis in
Wuhan one exacerbated by tactics that
have left the city of 11 million with a
death rate from the coronavirus of 4.1%
as of thursday staggeringly higher than
the rest of the country's rate of 0.17%
with the sick being herded into
makeshift quarantine camps with minimal
medical care a growing sense of
abandonment and fear has taken hold in
Wuhan fueling the sense that the city
and the surrounding province of Hebei
are being sacrificed for the greater
good of China's they are literally
hurting people into quarantine centers
where they have basically no medical
care and assuming that a lot of those
people are just going to die because
they don't have a basic medical care
well done communism everybody was paying
homage in the media to the fact that
they built a hospital in ten days look
what they can do when they put their
minds to it yes and when you activate
capitalism in that direction you can do
this stuff much faster and much better
but basically this entire city has now
been turned into a quarantine Center
because communists did not pass the
information up the chain because they
did not make public the information
because they did not call for help for
outside resources and because they knew
that in a pinch they could always do
something like this the harsh new moves
in Wuhan the epicenter of the outbreak
clearly signaled the ruling
parties alarm that it had failed to gain
control of the corona virus epidemic
which is overwhelmed the country's
healthcare system and threatened to
paralyze China the world's most populous
country and second largest economy the
steps were announced by the top official
leading the country's response to the
virus Vice Premier son
Chun illan as she visited Wuhan on
Thursday they evoke two images of the
emergency measures taken to combat the
1918 Spanish flu pandemic they killed
tens of millions of people worldwide
despite the severity of the new measures
however they offered no guarantee of
success
apparently this looked like a military
campaign as son ordered medical workers
to mobilize into round-the-clock shifts
to visit each home in Wuhan check the
temperature of all residents and
interview close contacts of any infected
patients word of the new restrictions
arrived as the people who had received
an emotional gut-punch from the news
that a doctor who had warned of the
outbreak in December and was silenced by
police Ford had died from corona virus
infection and this is the other story
that tells you how garbage communism is
his name was dr. Lee wen Liang he issued
a warning about the strange new virus
back in December he was called up by the
cops he was arrested he was silenced
again according to the New York Times
who's the doctor who tried to sound a
warning that had troubled cluster of
viral infections in a Chinese province
could grow out of control and was then
summoned for a middle-of-the-night
reprimand over his candor because in
China first rule protect the party never
make the party look bad disease doesn't
exist in China just as poverty didn't
exist in the Soviet Union right just as
just as everything was working fine in
the Soviet Union rent loans all good
everybody that's bread because the first
priority is the protection of the party
and because the government can never be
wrong because the solution to all
problems is the government that means
that if you point out a problem and you
make it public and you make it public
that the government isn't doing anything
about the problem you are the problem on
Friday this dr. Lee wen Liang died after
contracting at the very illness he had
told medical school classmates about in
an online chat room
the corona virus he joined the more than
600 other Chinese who have died in an
outbreak that has now spread across the
globe
according to Wuhan at Central City
Hospital dr. Lee had the misfortune to
be infected during the fight against the
novel coronavirus pneumonia epidemic and
all-out efforts to save him failed we
express our deep regret and condolences
in early January who was called in by
both medical officials and the cops and
forced to sign a statement announcing
his warning as an unfounded
illegal rumor top-down systems of
government control aren't they wonderful
he points out that there's a problem and
the first reaction is call him in and
have the medical authorities shut him
down but they're scientists guys they're
bureaucrats scientific bureaucrats we
should always trust them rather than
people who are attempting to alert us to
real danger one comments are posted and
replied to the hospital's announcement
we will not forget the doctor who spoke
up about an illness that was called
rumor what else can we do the only thing
is not to forget dr. Lee was 34 he was
expecting a second child with his wife
he had been a relatively obscure
ophthalmologist in Wuhan the capital of
who by province in the epicenter of the
corona via virus but in recent weeks he
became a poke potent icon for Chinese
people angry that a viral outbreak had
swelled unchecked into a full-blown
crisis and that the doctor who had
spoken out was initially punished his
death poses a singularly delicate issue
for the Chinese government even as
officials have battled the epidemic
they've also tried to stifle widespread
criticism that they mismanaged their
response to the initial outbreak in
Wuhan a city of 11 million and in recent
days they've stepped up censorship again
which is always good news because lack
of information for the general public
when a pandemic is in the offing is
always good for the world
after a rush of online criticism and
investigative reports by emboldened at
Chinese journalists exposed to missteps
by officials who underestimated and
underplayed the threat of the corona
virus dr. Lee's death has also exposed a
troubling aspect of the epidemic that
goes unmentioned in official statistics
the number of doctors and nurses and
medical workers infected by the virus
some unverified pictures of what appear
to be government data have indicated
that hundreds of hospital workers may
have been infected in Wuhan and this
would be a particularly grave example of
the government failing and these doctors
and nurses if they knew that this corona
virus was particularly virulent and if
they knew how to protect their doctors
and nurses in the first place and they
didn't tell anybody well then those
deaths are on their hands earlier in the
outbreak a prominent infectious disease
expert said a single patient had
infected 14 medical workers at one
hospital the median of patients is
between 49 and 56 but dr. Lee was
unusually young to be infected by this
he said on December 30th in a chat room
that this result resembled SARS
not long after his reprimand who is
vindicated as thousands Wu hen residents
fell ill with fever and pneumonia
symptoms when the announcement came that
he had died many comments accused the
authorities of having sought to prolong
dr. Lee's life until deep in
the night to show that to hide the news
of his death and China is a horrible
country to live in we try to pretend
that they're not a horrible country
because presumably we don't want to
acknowledge that they are a nascent
Soviet Union just in a different part of
the world but as much as we try to
pretend they will be what they will be
and that country is a one-party
dictatorship the communism always always
a failure always a giant fail alright
we'll be back here later today with two
additional hours of content also
questions in the mailbag so make sure
you send your questions in by
subscribing it daily we're DICOM use
code DW 2020 and we'll see you here in a
little bit for two additional hours of
constant otherwise take the weekend off
you knock off tonight and take a couple
days off we'll see you here back on
Monday I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling assistant director Pavel lie
down scoop technical producer Austin
Stephens playback and media operated by
Nick's even associate producer Katie
swenerton edited by Adam sy events audio
is mixed by Mike poor amina hair and
makeup is by Anika Geneva the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 25 on the Matt
Walsh show we're not just discussing
politics we're talking culture faith
family all of the things that are really
important to you so come join the
conversation
[Music]